i love beauty beauty and design and food
are
really my passions and the cat eye is a
tricky
thing it's not the easiest makeup look
to master
but with a little practice and the right
products anyone
can do it so here's a few tips
on cat eyes now i have three different
approaches here we have the flower
beauty
uh foreverwear winged liner now this one
is a little bit of a felt tip pen so
what i like about these is that you can
hold it with a lot of control
and this is absolutely one of my
favorite ways to
achieve a cat eye another
is a nyx nyx professional
liquid liner and it's a matte um i love
nyx it's a fabulous company and this has
a little
brush on it it's a long brush so
some people prefer to paint their cat
eye
on that way and this is another
alternative this is l'oreal
and this has a brush as well but it's
very short brush
so really i would look closely on
websites and visual references to see
what you're most comfortable with and
i'm going to go with our felt pen
i wouldn't go all the way to the corner
i would
start right about here and then you just
want to follow
the lash line to start and then
you can decide what kind of wing
you want you can also pull the flesh
because mine's creeping over
i feel like meryl streep and it's
complicated
also another really important tip have a
pointy q-tip at the ready and a little i
have a little
bowl of makeup remover and that way you
can go in
and just give a little perfection
with a little remover all right so
that's all you have to do
and then you can shape it accordingly so
pointy q-tips makeup remover and the
right tip
to your preference is a great way to go
about doing the cat eye follow the lash
line and then go as dramatic or subtle
as you like
all right